what's up people back with Jena grad and
Jena I don't know where you get your sex
toys from but I get mine from Lions Den
calm and do you know why because they
put out this kitschy little Christmas ad
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I thought this was kind of
great like it's got like I did it's got
look the 15 shades of gray thing yeah a
little you know sexify holidays a little
bit now you
I assume knew what all those toys were
right I don't have to explain any of
those I will wrap that up in one word
yeah yeah yeah did you think it was
creepier than I just thought it was kind
of funny and I like people who use this
kind of okay I got a Santa Claus and a
dildo you know yeah too much it got
thick right here to tell them yeah okay
look as a as a as a on-again-off-again
practicing Jew and somebody who's never
celebrated Christmas and wasn't allowed
to color in Santa pictures in class when
I was in fourth grade I am going to bat
for Santa Claus on this why would they
stop you from coloring in Santa picture
my internal I was I went up to the
teacher I was like I don't think I'm
supposed to color this in 2014 they
wouldn't hand you you know Santa Ana
cross and say do your best in a public
school but this was a different time
I am super grossed out by this I'm super
offend as a lover of sexual free
expression and a lover of all things not
christmas-related
I really feel offended by this yeah it's
so gross I don't mean to be like prude
but like Santa is such like a coveted
image of a sexless image we're just you
know the children and the toys and not
like the like dangling a [ __ ] ring in
front of a secretariat it's not it's not
comfortable it's not funny the dangling
of the [ __ ] ring that's not a Christmas
tradition is that maybe that's where the
wreath came from that exactly that's
possible I mean I thought it was kind of
like I just there's something about
these companies that do these kind of
things like they're just it's just silly
but I but one thing that thought was
really interesting is I think we need to
give the Christians a little credit I
may be Christians in this country get
bashed relentlessly of course every
group
they're extremists that makes everybody
else look bad the fundamentalists that
take the fun out of everything
exact and the mental back in that's
pretty good is that yours I just made it
up you made that up
that's Wow I mean you got to do things
that hey I think we do have to give them
a little bit of credit here because you
know every day that I watch a repeat on
a Family Guy
right you know there's something with
Jesus going on literally they had Jesus
in Bethlehem he was like sponge bathing
himself while Stewie was watching and
they were playing like porno music and
then you know Santa Claus his tricks
were dead so there's a gajillion example
so that and then you know this kind of
Santa sexy Santa thing and nobody gets
upset by it and I think there's some
worth like everywhere world we're all
the outrage machine all the time right
we're and I thought there's something to
be said that like nobody's gonna make a
big deal about this and that's actually
good I totally agree yeah I think that
save your outrage for something that
actually matters but like but that going
with taste yeah that it leaves a bad
taste now if this had been a sexier man
would you feel differently is this
because he's a imminently older man if
he said Jon Hamm in a velvet hat
everybody would be fine with it nobody
would say boo but this was this was a
portly mall Santa you know with his come
hither stare looking you know like [ __ ]
was gonna get Randy what do you think of
Jon Hamm in a what was he in in a velvet
hat let us know in the comments right
down below